So good morning.
Today we're going to be talking about opera,
particularly opera of the 19th century.
This is actually the third opera that we have engaged in our course.
And it occurs to me that I should ask you the names of the other two.
Can you remember any of the other operas that we looked at,
albeit briefly in this class?
That is Don Giovanni by Mozart.
That was the one we had a run at acting out particular scenes of.
We enjoyed it.
Uh,
and what was the other one earlier?
One that we,
um,
uh,
heard at least an Aria out of is it layer layer athlete,
Dido and the niece of Henry personal taking us back into the 17th century.
So we had a 17th century opera in 18th century opera.
Now we come to 19th century opera,
19th century opera.
As you may know,
if you've piqued their in chapters 26,
27 28 of your textbook,
uh,
concerns two figures in particular,
one or rijkaard Bogner and the other Giuseppe Verdi.
And we've had some music of Wagner before.
What was the big Aria that we dealt with out of his opera?
Tristin remember that?
What was that?
Had An interesting name that he is again the liebers tope believers tote of
Ricard Wagner.
Um,
but we've had some Wagner here in our course.
We've had no verity and I think it's,
uh,
it is probably why is there,
to focus on Verdi because Verdi in a way,
as much more representative of 19th century opera,
uh,
generally then is Wagner.
Wagner is a very special kind of thing that gets put on only in,
usually only involved in her festivals,
whereas Verdi in an odd way very,
and Mozart and Buccini are still sort of the staples of most opera companies
around the world.
Uh,
last night I went online just to see what was happening with Italian opera Verdi
and particularly La Traviata.
Uh,
and immediately of course the first thing you get in any kind of Google search
is somebody trying to sell you tickets to something.
But I was just interested how many opera houses around the world.
You could buy tickets for La Traviata tonight,
tomorrow night,
or the next night.
And it turns out that there are five opera houses in the United States playing
La Traviata Thursday evening,
one of them at the metropolitan opera.
So,
uh,
this gives you a sense that hey,
this is really popular.
This is what a opera companies are really working with.
So we're going to focus on Giuseppe Verdi here in particularly La Traviata.
A Verdi is an interesting case.
We've dealt with lots of musical prodigy such as Machar.
Uh,
in an odd way.
Very at the beginning of his career was an abject musical failure.
He tried to get into,
we applied for admission to the conservatory of Milan and was rejected.
He tried to get a job as the director of music at his,
uh,
small farming community of boosts Eto in northern Italy near Parma and was
turned down for that job.
So we got a job as the town band of master ultimately,
but he was,
uh,
he persevered.
He continued to write operas,
uh,
and then eventually he got one the performed at La Scala.
Now La Scala is the main opera house in Milan.
So that was successful.
And on the basis of that success,
then impresarios producers around the world contacted Verdi and try to convince
him to write operas for their theaters.
And he did,
and eventually his career spread even North America and South America.
So let's take a moment and look at the opera that Verdi compose.
You have a list over there putting the Buco on because that's the one that
launched his career really in Milan 1842.
Uh,
then we have a series there in the middle.
Rigoletto Il Trovatore,
ray La Traviata.
These are sometimes called is more domestic,
uh,
type of,
um,
uh,
opera subjects rather than historical ones.
Uh,
then we move on the to later works.
You can see Don Carlos there,
another historical one.
I Eda for the opening of the Suez Canal Otello and false staff based off of the,
I guess the merry wives of Windsor.
So you can see a couple of points here.
Uh,
one that very lived a long time and it was active as a creative artist for a
very long period of time.
Any other artists have a longer productive career than Verdi?
There's one painter working in the 20th century.
Think about it a minute.
Picasa yeah,
from about 1905 until it really,
the time of his death in the early 1970s,
I guess.
Uh,
so he was productive in case of Verdi for five or six decades there.
And notice also the importance of Shakespeare here.
Lots of Shakespeare,
he's sitting Shakespeare was the dominant literary figure of the 19th century.
So let's turn our attention now to La Traviata.
It's based on a play of Alexander Dumas.
Alexon grow Dumas,
uh,
feasts actually pair Ackman's to be on the cover of our textbook.
Uh,
the son wrote a play called the Lady of the Chameleon Chameleon is a white
flower.
Um,
and the play was simply staging,
uh,
a true life story involving this playwright Alexandre Dumas,
the younger and his love affair with a young lady named Lee do play cease.
Uh,
you have a picture of mafia who place these in page one,
page three Oh two of your textbook.
Uh,
she was a girl from the country who by a liberal allocation of charm and an even
more generous distribution of her virtue.
Managed to sleep her way to the top of Parisian society at that time.
Let's try to think this morning.
I don't know very much about popular culture.
Um,
but who would be like that today?
I don't know.
I Paris Hilton,
people like I,
I,
I don't know,
but,
uh,
it,
she would,
it was kind of the tabloid figure of the 19th century.
So much so that I was struck.
I came upon this reasonably Charles Dickens,
you don't think of Dickens and Paris Hilton in the same sentence normally,
but Charles Dickens in far away England at this time.
Notice that Marie do play Csun Paris when she died and she died into this
shockingly young age of 23 when she died a dick and said the following,
you would have thought her passing was a question of a life and death or the
death of a hero such as Joan of arc.
So obviously again,
sort of cap capturing everyone's attention in any of it.
We're going to watch a lot Traviata on a video and that video will be on a
reserve for you.
And you've got some hints about that.
On that flip side of your sheet,
everybody got the sheet for today,
it says opera news and be watching a video.
Uh,
and you'll see there that these scene is set in Paris about 1845.
So this is core romantic time core romantic place,
Paris,
1845,
la Traviata.
What does that mean?
Well,
if you break it down in terms of its syllables,
you get the following law.
Feminine article,
I Guess Tra,
uh,
on the other side of the via is a road ta is a feminine thing.
Uh,
so we have the woman that's,
it's sort of fallen off the beaten path or the expected road here.
She's the woman who has gone astray.
She is a kept woman.
A court doesn't,
uh,
if you will,
sort of high class hooker here and at the moment she is,
um,
under the protection of one bottle.
Do Fool.
He's the bad guy in,
in our opera,
the bad guy on our video,
the opera opens at a party,
incomes.
Our hero,
his name is Alfredo.
So the love couple here,
the,
the love interest Alfredo Violeta Violetta is the woman going astray.
So Alfredo comes in and he proposes a toe.
So we're going to listen to a little bit of our first music.
Uh,
this morning I will probably be breaking up this music and commenting more than
I normally would for reasons of copyrights.
Uh,
I needn't say more go into that,
uh,
more than that,
but in break it up a little bit more than I normally would.
So let's listen to a little bit and think about here.
Think of the meter.
Think of the mode as we listened to this opening chorus.
Okay,
let's pause it here for a second.
You have the text,
it's the opening scene Aria here.
Alfredo.
Um,
at the top there,
waltz and drinking song.
[inaudible] let us drink,
let us drink and so on.
Let's have a good time.
Uh,
what about the mode in the meter?
Basic question.
Well,
if it's a waltz,
has gotta be trip?
Okay.
Do we have a fast trip up?
Boom.
Pop,
pop,
pop.
Uh,
in the mode.
Major,
minor,
minor.
Let's listen to some more.
What about that cord?
Major.
Minor.
So it's all in major.
All in major.
So we have a happy,
joyful sort of crowd scene led by Alfredo here.
Uh,
then he steps forward to announce his two professors love to via Lotta,
he's been admiring her from afar.
And we have the first major Aria.
Here you have your sheet and you can see the Arrow pointing to it.
Ooh,
Andy Fetty j uh,
and let's listen to a bit of this now and the same question to you.
Uh,
the mode and,
uh,
the meter of this.
We're gonna listen to a little bit and then we'll talk about tempo here.
So let's pay particular attention to tempo and meter.
So let's go into,
let's go on to the next,
just a,
the next CD.
I'm sorry.
It should be CD,
uh,
three.
They're probably track too.
Very beginning.
That's my fault.
Here we go.
Okay.
Where's the beat?
Got It.
Stand up and conduct with,
no,
don't stand up.
A nice big beat.
Very good.
Okay.
All right.
So we've got an a nice slow triple meter here.
Uh,
and what about the,
it's mostly major bit sort of tinge,
a little bit with minor.
Let's watch what happens to the,
to the tempo.
Now we're going to do them two,
three,
one,
two,
three,
a little bit more.
Oh,
Yay.
so what happened?
Well,
obviously the tempo slowed way,
way down there,
and we have this term for this.
It's a part and parcel of the romantic romantic era called tempo.
Rubato flexibility,
a more unstable tempos here.
Again,
part of the instability in a way,
and the mercurial switches back and forth of mood of the romantic period.
Tempo.
Robota literally means robbed.
Rubato means robbed something.
Robbed.
Well,
here the tempo is rob.
We're taking away,
we're showing the way down here,
and then it will speed back up to catch catch back up.
So it's kind of like a slinky.
The slinky had as a kid.
He put it on the stepping go really fast and slow too over the top and showed.
So that's what sort of what tempo Rubato yes.
So let's listen to a little bit more.
Oh,
here's a shift of minor on the word mystery.
oh,
more rubato.
They're slowed way down.
Okay,
let's pause it here just for a second.
Now via led to is going to come in and I would ask you,
how does Violetta's music and differ from the music of Alfredo?
I'll be able to think of a couple of ways here.
Let's listen to Violetta.
Okay.
So we'll pause it there.
So how has that music differ from what we've just heard?
Anybody?
Jerry?
It's faster.
All right.
Pick the basic.
It's faster.
Uh,
what did you sense about it?
Darker or lighter?
Probably lighter.
It's and it's higher in range and it's a little bit flighty and it's more
disjunct.
And this is what composers,
composers do.
They tried to depict characters.
So right off the bat we have this kind of live for the moment,
character of Violetta coming here.
She doesn't want to have anything to do with this mystery of love that Alfredo
was proposing here.
Um,
Eh,
and this is what Verdi was good.
I didn't mean this is what Mozart was a very good at.
One of the things we should have noticed about lovely duet that Richard Lolly
and Linda saying the other day,
Laci Darren,
no,
was it as they were singing,
Mozart was writing music in which they were rests in between each entry of the,
of the singers.
And then there's that duet went on and we didn't even notice.
But it's crucial to the effect of the,
uh,
of the duet.
As the duet went on,
the,
the length of those rest got smaller and smaller and eventually they
disappeared.
Uh,
and what Mozart isn't telling us here is that just as physical as,
as sonic space is disappearing,
so to the distance between these two individuals is disappearing.
They're getting closer together musically as a,
as they're getting closer together physically,
and then ended up with
right together in parallel thirds there so much are kind of brings this music
altogether.
Well,
watch what happens here.
Who's going to win out?
Is Violetta's light music going to win out?
Is Alfredo gonna start singing like Violetta or is Violeta going to start
singing like Alfredo?
Let's listen a bit more.
Hello,
right there.
So who won?
Who?
God has his or her way.
Uh,
Alfredo,
right?
So she came down in her range,
she shifted to slightly minor tinted sound and that the tempo of the music
slowed down.
So he sort of won that contest of musical wills there.
A musical characterizations should want to listen to a little bit more of this.
And now we want to shift our attention over to the issue of the relationship
between the voice and the orchestra.
And this is very different than what happens in Wagner.
So we're listening here to a typical setup of Verdi and what is the relationship
of the voice and the orchestra?
What is the orchestra doing here?
Let's pause here.
Uh,
what's the orchestra doing?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Little sort of Pitsa cadeau support underneath.
Not much more.
Let's listen to a bit more here and see what the orchestra is doing.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Hello.
Oh,
what's is here?
What's the orchestra doing?
Absolutely none.
It's disappeared completely.
What is this?
What's going on?
Well,
this is the period of the great period of Bel Canto singing.
Literally Bel Canto,
just made sure,
beautiful song,
beautiful song singing where all of the attention is focused on the voyage.
That's what the audience is paying to come to here.
They don't care if you almost get amplified guitar underneath there and play
that,
that accompany mint.
So it's all in the voices here.
And again,
this is very different than the Orca or cash really dominated score of Wagner.
So let's listen to the end of this Aria voices alone.
Oh,
okay.
oh,
So that's the first big Aria together and needed to do it.
Now we're going to want to move on here in La Travie artists to something
called,
uh,
Shayna and Ushana to the Italian word for Sheena of course is simply seen.
But in opera it's a little bit more,
a little bit more complex than that.
Um,
what we have is a,
um,
an amalgam of three items.
We have a recitative,
excuse me,
an Aria followed by a recitatives followed by another Aria.
And that final Aria is a very fast Aria.
Indeed,
it's something called a capital letter that we'll talk a little bit about later
on.
So now we're moving on our text sheet here to the second Arrow where we have an
aria sung by Violeta.
She saying to herself,
she's off by herself.
Ah,
perhaps she is or he is the one that I have been waiting for.
Maybe this is finally the great true love of my life.
Let's listen to a little bit of this.
Hmm.
All right,
we'll stop.
There obviously is an Aria because there's so much attention on just producing
sound sliding all the way up to that high note there and it happens to be in a
minor key.
Then she begins to reflect further on this and she says,
well no,
this is not what I want to do.
Think about my situation here.
Here I am in Paris alone and abandoned.
We're going to go on to the next to Arrow here down a little bit below.
Fully your folio Deleo von [inaudible] questo pull that.
I don't,
uh,
poor lady,
solo abandoned,
not the inquest or popular.
So [inaudible] g k sparrow or Pew Kfr Day.
Joe,
what am I going to do?
Well,
I'm going to enjoy myself.
So what we have here is a to teeth,
but it's a different kind of recipe to teeth than we've had up to this point in
our course.
Up to this point,
we've had rested to teeth called simple recitative and this is the recipe,
the teeth of the 17th and 18th century,
that in which the particular proponent will be going along and trying to relate
what has happened in that time.
And then we'd come to the end of the Shag,
something like that.
It would be a company very lightly by a keyboard underneath and that that's kind
of all the tech company.
But now we move on to a bigger kind of accompany a or Casserly accompanied
recitatives got this fancy Italian sounding word,
[inaudible] auto.
We could pronounce it that way.
Or just say accompanied rest at the teeth.
It's the same.
It's the same,
same deal.
You get the full orchestra accompanying rather than just the keyboard.
So let's listen to a good example of 19th century recipe to teeth,
but rested to teeth that is fully accompanied.
Yep.
So here we are at the third,
yeah,
era.
A lot of tremolo
strings.
What am I going to do?
Cape federal data.
Okay,
well this is a very joyful setting of the word joy.
[inaudible].
The third part of our Sheena begins now we have the beginning of Fast Aria.
It's called a cab Aleta.
It's an operatic device.
It usually appears at the end of the scene in order to allow the protagonists to
make,
uh,
a strong declaration or an emphatic statement and then enthusiastically,
um,
uh,
exit stage left or stage right.
It's a kind of convention to get the protagonist off the,
off the stage.
Let's listen to a couple of seconds of this.
We're going to come back to this particular Kalb.
Aleta Sim pre Libra.
It's a famous one.
Virtually every major soprano has sung it,
um,
in which at the vows to remain always free.
Simpler,
stop
it there.
We will come back to that.
But of course the electorate doesn't remain free.
She used to,
comes to the advances of Alfredo.
The two of them live blissfully,
blissfully together for awhile.
Then she coral separate.
Ultimately they are reunited after a period of time.
Uh,
but she is developed consumption,
tuberculosis.
This sort of age of the,
of the 19th century.
Uh,
and the,
uh,
she dies at the end of the opera.
We've talked about this convention of opera before.
Remember,
it ain't over til the fat lady sings.
That's,
that's,
uh,
probably a silly remark about opera in this case.
It ain't over until the thin lady sings because on our video we have the,
a role of Violetta Sung by Teresa Strada,
the very thin Teresa strata.
And uh,
she is a very fine actress.
Indeed.
That's why she was chosen for this.
A video,
a video production.
So that in brief is the story of La Traviata and you've got a video of it.
I asked you to what scenes Outta it's um,
directed by Franco Zeffirelli and it was a production he put together in the mid
1980 [inaudible] and it's still used at the met.
Again,
if you go there Thursday night,
if you can pony up the be the expensive,
the big bucks for the tickets.
Boy,
are they expensive?
Um,
uh,
you can see this as Zeffirelli production,
um,
with different singers of course,
than those on the video.
But it's still being produced that all the sets and the costumes and all exactly
as you will see it there in your video.
Okay.
So now what I want to do with the rest of the,
uh,
of the session today,
having established a little bit about Verdi and a little bit about La Traviata
is talk about singers' voices.
What to listen for,
uh,
with regard to singers.
When we went to the Saybrook Orchestra concert and we went to the Jonathan
Edwards makeup concert,
we were engaging a critical ear with regard to hearing instrumental sounds or
Kestrel.
Sounds.
Well,
now we want to do the same thing,
uh,
with regard to a vocal sounds.
So what is it that makes a good operatic singer?
Anybody in here take ever take some voice lessons?
I bet you have.
Don't be bashful now,
Kristen.
Okay.
Did you ever try singing any opera?
Oh,
good for you.
Uh,
well,
tell us about it.
Uh,
I don't mean to put you on the spot here.
do you remember that?
What was any particular opera that you remember?
Yeah,
Johnny sqeaky.
Oh,
how interesting.
That has that beautiful Amil Bambino cargo,
uh,
that we used as an example of melody a little bit earlier in,
in our,
um,
in our course.
Um,
so,
uh,
by Puccini of course.
Uh,
so let's talk about this for a minute.
What constitutes a good operatic voice,
which may be a little bit different than what constitutes a good church voice or
a good synagogue voice,
um,
or a good mosque voice,
top of him in or rent,
whatever it might happen to be.
Um,
we're talking opera here.
What do you need to have a good operatic voice?
What would you guess?
Well,
nice tone,
a nice tone and the tone is kind of even from top to bottom.
Oftentimes you run into singers that have what's called a break in their voice,
uh,
in might have one tone quality in the lower register and then you can hear it
shift into a different tone,
quality in the upper registered.
So you would,
we don't want that.
We want to kind of smooth quality,
uh,
from,
beginning to end.
A richness of tone,
color,
richness of tone,
uh,
other things.
Roger,
you had your hand up.
Anything you want to add to that?
Okay.
Project the voice.
That's very important.
You've got to have a powerful voice.
You have to have a powerful voice because of your singing at the met.
This came up in my section the other day.
Are you allowed to have microphones there?
Okay.
No,
not at the metropolitan opera.
You have to have natural voices going to fill that auditorium of (252) 062-0700
people.
If you go to a Broadway show,
are the singers amplified by microphones there?
Phantom of the opera?
Yes,
they certainly are.
And we've talked about that,
how that sound.
There's picked up and immediately sent to a mixing board in the back and there's
an electronic engineer.
They're manipulating that sound,
but for opera singers,
they,
you don't get to do that.
You have to have a powerful voice that's going to fill the hole and they want
you to fill the hall.
They want to fill the hall cause they got to sell,
sell tickets.
So they want big holes.
So you have to a powerful voice.
What about the quality of the voice?
Well,
it,
the bigger the hall,
oftentimes you have to generate of a broader,
right?
And we've talked about that with string players,
but what's the,
the liability of a Bronto?
Okay,
well sometimes it can get so big that it becomes uncomfortable.
What is the pitch please?
So we have to have a well focused voice.
You have to have a powerful voice or well-focused voice,
uh,
and so on.
So let's listen to a couple of famous singers here in the course of the,
of the 20th century.
Um,
I struck by this cause a lot of my acquaintances like this music.
I was interested this morning that our camera man Juge said that each morning
his mother listens to Pavarotti in both Chaley.
So here is Andrea both Chaley.
Um,
and let's listen to a little bit of his singing.
How many of you know who this fellow boat Chaley is?
Most of you.
Okay.
He frequently owned television.
So listen a little bit of Andrea Bocelli and we'll focus,
try to come in on his voice.
Tommy,
Tommy
[inaudible].
But before I get in trouble.
Um,
what do you think of that voice?
What are you think of that sound?
Would you buy that?
Is that opera?
Well it's a little bit,
it's kind of an operating voice.
Actually.
He studied with Pavarotti.
Is it as good as papa?
Right.
His voice.
I,
we don't have all morning to focus on this.
No,
it's not as good as papa brought his voice.
He goes in the upper register.
You can't hold the notes for as long.
It's more pinched.
You feel that he's uncomfortable there in terms of the style of this music,
is that,
why is this not,
and this is something,
what makes this not a real opera?
Aria here are different than an opera Aria.
Right at the beginning of June,
June,
June.
It's much more rhythmic,
right?
It's got a back beat to it and has a strong base component and a strong rhythmic
component.
It's what I call pop up or op pop.
Either way.
Popular opera,
popular pop bro,
whatever.
Um,
is it kind of blend between the two?
So it's somewhere between opera and poppy pop music.
Let's go on now to talk about the two tenors that have dominated the 20th
century and one of them continues to dominate in the 21st century.
Luciano Pavarotti and Placido Domingo.
Okay.
Um,
let's start with Domingo.
Really developed as a baritone voice,
then a second tenor,
and then pushed himself up into the higher range to sing first tenor,
but not initially trained as a first Tinder.
Um,
a highly intelligent man,
a great actor,
a conductor,
a,
it's fascinating.
Sometimes he will sing the matinee and then in the evening we'll go into the pit
to conduct an opera.
So of really impressive musician,
but maybe not the voice of Pavarotti.
Let's listen to the two of them seeing the same passage.
And we have this at the bottom of your sheet here.
Um,
it's a kappa Leta in which the hero Alfredo vows to wash away the sin that has
been visited on his family.
Family's going to wash away this disgrace.
So he,
he's going to say,
I'm going to wash this away and then he's going,
going to exit the stage.
So let's listen to a Domingo seeing this passage.
You have the text again at the bottom of your sheet.
[inaudible]
okay,
no comment.
Let's go on out to listen to Luciano Pavarotti.
Sing the same passage.
Turn it down.
Just a hair.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
so what's the difference?
Yeah,
let me two things there that immediately edited.
Oh,
Roger,
you just look a stronger voice.
He has a stronger,
more powerful voice.
I had to ask Linda to turn down the volume.
It's huge and it's rich.
It's rich too.
Um,
anything else there?
You were talking about?
Uh,
Emily.
Is it?
Huh?
Yeah.
You heard at the end there?
I was starting to look at my watch just as it,
uh,
Domingo held that note for four seconds.
It's like a diving contest or something.
We're going to hold up a 10 or seven after this jump here,
but Domingo held this for four seconds.
Pavarotti held it for 11 seconds.
I mean,
just hugely high note.
Uh,
I think it's a high seat.
It's way up here.
I don't know.
It was somebody would absolute pitch and tell us what,
that was a hugely high note.
I'll let you just sat on this thing.
Powerful,
beautiful tone.
It really is.
It was amazing.
Now I think through the marvels of modern technology here,
uh,
and we may crash and burn.
We will find out a take a look here at Pava Rati singing what might have been
his signature Aria Nessun dorma out of Turin.
Dot.
And you have tour in dot disgust in the exoticism chapter of your textbook.
And the setup here as Linda queues,
this particular is that he,
um,
uh,
Nessun dorma means no one will sleep.
He's going to go out and find the answer to the riddle that will allow him to be
successful in his conquest of this ice cold,
uh,
princess that he wants to,
um,
uh,
make,
Morris advances upon.
So what do you think?
Do we have it queued there to the right spot?
So here's Luciano Pavarotti singing.
Whoops,
we got to go to one 55 because we get,
we don't have time to listen to all of it.
So this is the end of Nessun.
Dorma and here's Pavarotti was Zubin Mehta conducting the New York Phil.
Okay.
And thanks to Linda for helping me out and getting all these things up in
bookmarks and cute and things.
It be slightly
okay.
That's all right.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll have a little
hello.
Oh,
Tom.
Okay.
So that's the great Luciano Pavarotti.
And he was great.
I mean,
in terms of male voices I've ever heard in,
I listen to a bit of this going back tracking in the 20s and they never heard
anything like this in the entire 20th century.
But a word of caution,
you can go on youtube here and you'll see Pavarotti picture coming up with the
same,
same Aria,
maybe four or five different recordings of it.
When was Pavarotti really good?
And when did he stop being really good?
Don't buy anything of rocky after 1980,
uh,
from 78 79 80.
That's the heyday of Pavarotti.
His recordings,
and they're spectacular.
I mean,
nobody could touch this guy,
but they're after.
They really do begin to decline.
And you could do comparative comparisons of these,
of these various recordings over time to have to watch the decline.
Then it's sort of sad,
but it's the natural process of the aging of the voice and the aging of the
body.
Um,
so now we're going to talk about the ladies.
We have a number of,
of different voice terms here,
vocal terms,
Volkl terms,
applying to particular registers.
The lowest part of the female operatic register is called the control tobe.
Uh,
and there's some of floating around,
used to be Maria Maureen forester across the street at our school of music.
Uh,
lily [inaudible] used to sing at the metropolitan opera.
She teaches,
I was still teaching at the school of music.
Uh,
I went to school with a woman named Joyce Castle Castrato,
uh,
frequently singing with the met.
So that's the kind of low part,
the Alto,
if you will,
of the,
of the female voice in opera.
Then we have the mezzo soprano,
kind of half soprano Metso,
Mezzo Forte,
half a,
that's between an alto and a soprano.
Frequent.
We,
we've had here at Yale Frederica bunch daughter.
She's a good example of a,
of a mezzo soprano sneaking up into the soprano range.
Then we have a soprano voice called the lyric soprano.
Uh,
so we're up in the high part of the female range,
the lyric soprano,
lovely sound,
a smooth sound.
We also have a soprano called a dramatic soprano.
Uh,
and these are voices like Kiersten flight stead beer get Neilson.
And more recently Jane Eagan,
uh,
Debra void.
These are the women that seeing Wagner and seeing Strauss where you really need
super superhuman large voices with plenty of powerful well-focused abroad,
a little broad vibrato.
And then finally we have a voice,
a range called the Coloratura,
very top part of the soprano range.
Very high.
Ken's to be light hinged if good tends to be well focused.
What does a Coloratura sound light?
We don't have a visual here,
but we do have the leading,
I think coloratura today.
Natalie decide,
uh,
singing just a bit of the,
of something called the Coloratura Soprano.
Uh,
just to give you a sense of what a coloratura sounds like.
Oof that up a bit.
Funny.
We just brought up this clip this morning.
We have a little trouble with computers.
Okay,
here she goes.
You should go.
All right.
That's probably,
that's probably not,
you get the idea.
Hi and light.
That's what the color a tour is all about.
Now we're going to focus on for sopranos singing the same Aria by way of
comparison here.
Um,
and,
uh,
the Ra in question is the part of that Shana that we were dealing with before.
I'll say for Louie,
fully folio and ultimately separate Libra.
We're first ApprenNet we're gonna start with is Nellie Melba?
She was an Australian soprano and was the leading a prima Donna around the turn
of the 20th century.
So this recording,
thanks Linda.
We got some surface noise here.
Uh,
John,
would you get the maybe?
Oh,
I guess one just got it.
Um,
this particular recording was made here and our own historical sound collection
off of,
uh,
of old vinyl.
Uh,
it goes back to 1905.
So here's Nelly Melba stinging.
You said a very interesting voice.
Tell me what you think about it.
Put two adjectives with this voice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
uh,
what did you think?
Okay.
Santana and Linda,
you're both professional singers.
What did you think of Nellie Melba here?
Your,
your head is elsewhere,
but any thoughts?
I love it,
but it sounds like you're allowed to be much smaller.
Okay.
Yes,
I love it.
But it sounds like you,
you're allowed to have a much smaller voice.
The Wagnerian voice hadn't carried the whole world at this point.
And we think that this is much more typical of 19th century scene,
well focused,
right on pitch,
uh,
but lighter perhaps something closer to the Coloratura.
Now we're going to move on for reasons of time to another video and we're going
to hear the dominant a Prima Donna of the mid 20th century.
And that was Maria Callas.
Anybody ever heard of Maria Callas?
Okay.
All the way.
All the way in the back.
She was,
uh,
something of a fashion statement,
a farm fatale and soprano that dominated the operatic stage in the 1950s.
Let's listen to a bit of her singing.
Let's see if you like it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hello?
Let's stop it there.
He liked that sound.
Yes or no.
How many Lichen I may don't like.
It reminds me of one town that California recently passed her a couple of years
ago,
passed an ordinance.
You get the vagrants out of this particular shopping center,
they would pipe nothing but Maria callous over the,
over the public address system.
It's a very kind of sharp penetrating voice.
And the older she got,
the wider that Virbrato God.
So some people don't find that particular that sound particularly attractive.
Let's go on to,
uh,
not chronological order because I'm going to finish with somebody else.
But the raining and diva of today,
Renee Fleming from Rochester,
New York,
her mother is a public school teacher,
was a public school voice teacher in Rochester.
So she's just a hometown girl from Rochester here.
Uh,
but now she is the glamor girl,
the poster girl for all of the,
all sopranos in opera.
And I think we have a video of,
of the famous Renee Fleming always sells out to the mid,
uh,
singing the same kind of material.
And as we listen,
what interests me here is her capacity to control the voice.
Wow.
She started fat can sit that tone out there and just spin it this way or spin it
that way,
slow it down,
make it roll faster.
It really,
it may not be the biggest,
it not be the,
the most,
uh,
always the richest.
But boy it is.
Sure.
The most controlled of the sopranos that I have seen.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then finally we're going to hear from Oh,
question Daniel.
She's laying down.
Uh,
I don't know how they do it.
I'd never,
I have enough trouble standing up and singing,
but I guess you know,
you wonder about that,
how they can do that,
how they can keep that pressure and all reclined like that.
But they always do it.
It's not,
it was not unusual to see that.
And we're going to end here with a couple of things.
Joan Sutherland,
probably the greatest soprano of the 20th century.
She really also reached your peak about 1980 and she frame frequently saying
with Pavarotti and on the cds for your,
our course here,
I have chosen Pavarotti in Sutherland singing La Traviata because I get to
choose these particular cds,
that recordings to go on our cds.
Uh,
so here you're going to see a bit of Joan Sutherland.
She wasn't particularly distinguishes an actress,
but boy,
what a voice and what you're going to hear here,
and I'll play this very quickly,
we've got a,
um,
a a line.
It's going,
Eh,
okay.
She's going to add a soprano line here that goes,
jumps up an octave higher than Verdi actually wrote it.
And if you listen to,
uh,
um,
Fleming in this Aria Fleming,
we'll end here.
Sutherland.
Okay,
well,
octave higher.
So let's listen to this woman with a beautiful color tour,
a tour of a very well focused,
powerful in all ranges,
sort of the complete voice,
still loading take to get to the point where you want.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Um,
and then,
uh,
on the way out while we're loading this,
um,
we had the hop an era of Bza on our quiz,
and we're to have an alternative performance of [inaudible] hub,
an arrow.
So give us one minute here.
We'll finish up.
We're almost there,
I think.
Uh,
okay,
let's,
let's do it off of that.
Can we do it quickly off the CD?
No.
That too much trouble.
And in any event,
listened to your CD,
let's listen to your cds.
Let's go to our last clip.
You remember the hub and Arrow with the,
okay.
And so on,
descending chromatic scale Ostinato underneath.
I found a better version of this.
I don't know whether this is the dumbest thing you've ever seen.
Probably is more.
It's really funny.
I can't tell me.
Yeah.
No,
I don't know what kind of soprano voice this is,
but it sure is different.
Me.
Right.
Okay.
So let's,
let's see.
I don't,
I'm still after.
Okay.
Just,
just play,
just play whatever we got.
Yeah.
Here's Sutherland.